[موسيقى]
في صحراء مصر الغربية على بعد 500 ميل
جنوب القاهرة ستة ملايين لوح شمسي تحت أشعة
الشمس الحارة ، تم حظر
أحد أكبر محطات الطاقة الشمسية في العالم ،
إنه مشروع يفخر محمد أمير بأن
يكون جزءًا من وظيفته  له في جميع
أنحاء العالم ولكن هذه هي المرة الأولى
التي يعمل فيها على شيء بهذا الحجم
في وطنه بشكل جيد ، لقد كنت
أعمل في مجال الطاقة طوال حياتي عندما
سمعت عن هذا المشروع ، قررت
العودة ودعم المتشككين في
بناء هذا  مشروع المحرك الاسكتلندي
للطاقة الشمسية هي واحدة من عشرات الشركات العالمية
التي تعمل على تطوير الموقع ،
يمر قطاع الطاقة
بكمية هائلة من التغييرات مصر
كجزء من تغييره وهذا هو السبب وراء
شراء الحكومة المصرية
لخطة طموحة لتنويع
مزيج الطاقة هدف مصر  هو أن تشكل مصادر الطاقة
المتجددة 20٪ من مزيج الطاقة في غضون
عامين. Ben Ban جزء من
المعادلة ، حيث يرسل الموقع 1.5 جيجاوات من الطاقة
إلى الشبكة الوطنية بما يكفي لتشغيل
مليون ساعة.  نحن نسمي هذه المنطقة من
العالم هي الشمس المبنية ، ولديها إشعاع عالي ،
وسماء صافية ، ورطوبة منخفضة ، وكلها
ظروف مناخية مواتية
تجعلك تحصل على أقصى طاقة يمكنك الحصول عليها من
محطة طاقة بطيئة ، OMA مسؤولة عن
الحفاظ على تشغيل المحطة على مدار الساعة طوال أيام الأسبوع  إنه على
الإنترنت ، حيث لا يغلق Blair أبدًا حظر الحرق ،
فهو يوفر أكثر من الطاقة التي
تخلقها المحطة وتؤثر على
المجتمع المحيط ، إنه مشروع ضخم
يوفر مئات
فرص العمل بالطريقة التي ترى بها الأشخاص الذين
تطوروا من السكان المحليين إلى المهندسين ذوي المهارات العالية.
بداية جيدة لهما
، يساعد محمد وعمر في تقريب
مصر خطوة واحدة من هدفها المتعلق
بالطاقة المتجددة مع اقتراب اليوم من
نهايته ،
تمتص هذه اللوحات بأشعة
الضوء الأخيرة التي ترسل المزيد من الكهرباء لتشغيل
تحول الطاقة في مصر Anna
Stewart CNN
[موسيقى]
أنت